and good evening and welcome tonight
allegations of sexual depravity an
assault against teenage girls by the
leader of a fast growing fundamentalist
religious sect claiming 5 million
members worldwide with 1 million in the
United States in all 50 states the
church leader claims to be the apostle
of God and authorities say he told the
teenage girls he allegedly abused that
by refusing him they would be going
against God
[Music]
the church calls itself the light of the
world claiming members in 58 countries
its leader is 50 year old nasaan joaquin
garcia who began his career as a
minister in Arizona and Southern
California
he teaches that he is the apostle of
Jesus Christ just like his father and
grandfather who founded the church
videos posted by the church show his
devoted followers treating joaquin
garcia like a holy figure his
charismatic appeal has helped the church
spread from its roots in mexico across
the united states and beyond but behind
that or california authorities say there
is a dark side a cult of personality
used by joaquin garcia to take advantage
of some of his youngest followers on
monday night my office arrested na song
joaquin garcia california attorney
general's a view of the Sarah says
joaquin garcia and three of his church
leaders are charged in what he called a
major sex trafficking and sex abuse case
involving at least three teenage girls
who were in the church he called the
church leader sick and demented the type
of crimes that belong nowhere in our
society from human trafficking
production of child pornography oral
copulation rape statutory rape child
molestation extortion conspiracy and
more the Attorney General said the
beloved church leader was provided by
his followers with images of teenage
girls who were told to quote take off
their clothing touch each other's
breasts and vaginas and lick whipped
cream off each other's breasts unquote
they were parishioners if you wish to
call them that this is a it's a pretty
large organization I hesitate to call it
a Church mega church
and it has a lot of followers and these
are some people would probably call this
a case of brainwashing or where these
families are influenced the veil has
presently been set with regard to mr.
Garcia in the amount of fifty million
dollars that amount will remain the
church leader joaquin garcia is now
being held on a bail of fifty million
dollars at a hearing this week
prosecutors said they feared he would
flee the country if there was not such a
large veil because there is a real fear
that because he has this church with
more than a million followers that he
will raise the money and he will bail
himself out and if he bells himself out
he may try to flee to the place where he
had just come from when we captured him
at la airport back to Mexico or
somewhere else all of this comes as the
Church of the light of the world is in a
pitched battle in a small town in
Georgia called flowery branch where the
church has bought a huge tract of more
than 300 acres to create its own City
the plans include a church resort hotels
even a shopping center some other holy
suppers have drawn over a hundred
thousand participants for several days
how do you do that in a town with little
one-lane rural roads in some little
subdivisions how do you do that in a
town of 8,000 people local residents
have organized a determined opposition
to stop the church project they're just
gonna roll right over here little
flowers aware
David Nixon is among those against it
saying the church has similarities to a
cult it's more about the leader it's
more about his glory and and you can
only get through you know to have him
through this guy in his family and I
would say that they share more in line
with what people traditionally think of
as a cult Church leaders claim its
opponents in Georgia are racist and
unchristian Jack Freeman is a minister
in the light of the world Church what's
happening in Georgia is a is a war as a
battle we need to fight we are not going
to lay down and give up and allow
ourselves to be taken captive or move or
run off now with the new criminal
charges against church leader joaquin
garcia local residents in georgia say
they are more determined than ever to
keep the development out if it also
turns out that the hierarchy of the
church gets convicted of you know child
rape and sex trafficking well I think
that helps make our case even more
ironclad
with their leader the apostle of Jesus
Christ behind bars awaiting trial
members of the church were instructed to
pray for Joaquin Garcia and his deputies
and lawyer said he was targeted because
he was a man of the cloth and promised
he would soon be proven innocent
the false allegations leveled against
her church leader apostle nasan joaquin
garcia have caused our church a deep
sadness however our church community is
confident that our the allegations will
be proven false joining us now by skype
is alan sawyer a lawyer for the accused
apostle this is sort of thank you very
much for being here
your client remains behind bars fifty
million dollars bail that's the largest
ever in Los Angeles County thanks for
having me Brian yeah it's a very unusual
amount of bail and I think it's based on
a false premise that you should take it
into account the assets and the wealth
of a church and determining of
individuals bail the reason why is a
false premise is because prior to this
incident and after this incident the
church's finances are completely
separate for mr. Garcia's finances he
does not sign on any bank accounts he
cannot direct where money is sent and
the church has a bylaw and a rule that
says that their funds cannot be used for
criminal defense mr. Saur let me ask you
your client I take it is going to plead
not guilty he's gonna fight this
of course yeah he's gonna enter a plea
of not guilty we expect to have a bail
hearing next Friday and we're extremely
confident that he will be allowed to
have a reasonable bail and this case
will proceed and due course and you'll
be fine not guilty mr. Soria we have a
question for you from our control room
from executive producer Rhonda Schwarz
Rhonda Allen is the church doing its own
investing
Gatien of these allegations i have
general counsel in the church and it's
very likely that they will do some kind
of internal investigation but we as a
defense are running our own
investigation it's an independent but is
there any truth to this at all mr.
Sawyer
does he know these three girls I look at
we haven't been provided discovery yet
in this case which is unusual I mean the
the Attorney General did an
unprecedented press conference where he
he claimed my client was an animal
demented and sick and that is completely
inappropriate for a prosecutor to do the
presumption of innocence supposed to be
present in a case and we there should be
no attempt to taint the jury pool and I
think mr. Becerra across the line and
violated ethical standards in the press
conference on the allegations where
they've been presented at this point
well Alan Sawyer thank you very much
we'll keep tabs on what's going on as
the cork goes through the process